[Musik]
und damit coole hobby stelle ich mir
besonders wo ich führe name sowie unter
einer 20 grad kaltem wasser aber warum
tut man sich das dann auch im winter
geworden
ich beobachte die fußballer denen sie
zwei jahre im umfeld und auf social
media ihre inspiration denise rottewert
rekordhalter bahnhof nord über man muss
zwei stunden eindeutige wasser aushalten
er bespricht mit einiger regelmäßigkeit
exposition und im richtigem ein zb werde
immer viel weniger konnte buch ist sogar
dreht von miamis
batterien ewald schwörer die methode
und bis
aber was bringt die wie im hof methode
tatsächlich das möchte ich den nächsten
tag in den usa versuchen zu finden
[Musik]
einen tag bevor ich sie erst einmal das
wasser stieg mache ich die wm hautnah
begleitet von hollander höchstpersönlich
ich konnte es bis jetzt mal schnell und
tief stufe landluft uhse und halte sie
denn es wird man währenddessen leicht
schwindlig und die vorbehalte von
schüssel edelfinger und lippe das ergebe
auffangen aber nun mal
[Musik]
ich glaube es auch mal was du wie immer
wieder erwähnt mein körper 16 fähig als
ich glaube
mitte januar geht's dann los die nächste
ist tag wie die temperatur um den
gefrierpunkt taugliches wasser stiegen
sowas ist der erste tag vom minister
dass
er sich jetzt muss oder eben
roboter
ich an klasse mit der schwimmer um eine
lieblose mundart motiviert ziemlich ab
und zu als begleite
nach zweisatz vor der bigotte die sechs
geräte klima
es fällt mir schwer tat nicht
kontrollieren ich zwinge mich der
fluchtinstinkt zu befinden aber nach 100
minuten muss user mit dem trockenen
kommentaren die versprochenen glück
sommer
extrem cooles gefühl nach magstadt dass
man sich überwunden hat es wird so als
hätte apple stunden sport gemacht und
deswegen
die nächsten tag gar nicht verschiedene
orte und mache konsequent die admira weg
nach sieben tag wird sich nie einfacher
ich schaue schon drei minuten ins wasser
zu
tanzen
nun haben sie fast alle die sport im
wasser
nach umschwung lege mich immer sofort da
und frühere einer stunde lang aber war
mit dusche bringt mich weiter
danke dass ihr fahrer vor mir habe
zweifel ob es wird sie vielleicht mache
ich aber einfach nur bis falsch
zum vfb und briefe offizielle wim hof
instruktorin helena hefti ich möchte vor
ihre wisse was es nach dem easter
unterart merbeck mit dem mindset auf
sich hat und bereits drogen dass man am
anfang sagt wichtigsten ich mich gar
nicht
nichts wisse was da eigentlich und
lehrern der körper zu unterstützen mit
gedanken dass mir nicht gedanken störe
sondern mir gedanken wenn man es wichtig
ist vor allem das richtige meint sie
zusammen mit dem ort und trainings am
wirksamsten um simon bestimmt stärker
seit sie für bessere der physische und
psychische gesundheit ist ein grund
warum dem hof methode so viel anhänger
findet so auch die beiden kursteilnehmer
mit
aber es ist individuellen und ist
einfach wichtig dass
wir jetzt mit der methode nachschauen
und bin ich antworte
renate erzählt mir dass ich dank der
methode ihre stiefel schulter verbessert
hat
[Musik]
stelle neue förderschiene war lange
stark und und entspannt zurück fließen
1 vierter satz art macht man dann
liegestütze und hatte gleichzeitig luft
da nach sagt der stuttgarter wir jetzt
mal ganz komisch und ich bekam für mich
kurzzeitig
wahrscheinlich habe es übertrieben ich
bin froh bin in hallein erst einmal
als corradino macht aber doch lee die
zustand noch
ganz kleine mini panikattacken
oder
wird es nicht so aus er will eigentlich
gemeinsam einander mit panikattacken ist
dass mir stark atmet und co2 aber
du hast ja nicht angst dass du bist
und mental total in anderen ort und der
unterschied ist einfach mitmachen es
bewusst
[Musik]
jetzt aber zu der wolf garten stellen
offiziell mississippi einige vor über 20
instruktorin der schweiz ob im hof die
ausbildung abgeschlossen hat das könnte
zu bekunden die vergütung landes lernen
das gelang im wasser setzte die die
leistungsorientierte mit aktien oder
gibt es aber ludwig verkörpern das hilft
jedem
aus was so autoimmunerkrankungen sind
die krankheiten sich mit dem hof methode
therapieren das sind unglaublich ich
gerade aber jetzt steht mit sehr
schmalen fluss
zählen um 12 minuten lang um die
gewünschte effekt erziele sie bleibt
magischer braun länger drin
[Musik]
ich merke im vergleich mit der andere
dass sie trennt die mittlerweile gut
vertragen und auch weniger frühere noch
im sport vielleicht muss ich bald eine
mehrheit
[Musik]
nsn unique der polierten und jörg at
trinken unser körper schätzt sauber
und wärme und mehr laufen jetzt also
zurück zu ihrem abteil ich habe
viertelstunde dadurch berner altstadt
warum noch interessanter ansatz also
noch nicht dort wieder warm aber das
will ja nicht so genau und da mal
einfach als dass man nicht noch mal so
einen stört muss man da halt ein
bisschen mitreden sondern einfach
geblieben der fokus
[Musik]
sollte knapp buch haben es versucht
schon drauf und letzte nacht hat es auf
eine schnelle jetzt möglich sagt es ist
winter schwimmen
lithium project und hat so denkt was
macht der spender da
ich sage dass ich ja schon als lustiges
gewählt aber schlimmsten ist weil man da
auf wo es um sich und nach durch den
schnee das ist schon
einmalig merke ich habe das laufen im
schnee mini vor sollen lehrer verletzt
es fühlt sich so an wieder für panik nun
suche nach wiesbaden schuhe und bin
überrascht dass es das tatsächlich gibt
ich entscheide mich dann aber für
normale badeschuhe überhaupt so viel
kostet
es schien da mal mit das grenznahe
kommerzialisiert werden es gibt sogar
schon wiesbadener rosa zugang zum sehe
ich zwar für alle gratis es werde aber
chris und sauna und spa der abbitte
am tag sagt experiment triffid maria und
lotti
sie gedanklich vom schwimmen
ich stimme ihnen zu glückshormonen nach
dem sport macht wirklich spitzel ist
wichtig aber ist das placebo oder wer
durchtrennt die tatsächlich hormone
ausgeschüttet
zum darf keine beantworte fahre zum
tauchen und kalt experte georg staub
bezahlbar nur die sparte ist ein großes
einfach happy und bewusster atmung
waren wir noch wörter so oft beschrieben
den sieg ließen auf verhält dieses leyen
hält hält er das ist ja mittelteil dann
dass man einmal davon überwinden
lte ist einfach weil die wehr mit punkt
physikalischer und ich setze mich jetzt
einmal gruseln und morgen etwas passiert
die müssen das jetzt mögliche visionen
angehen es gibt vielleicht sogar
geschmerzt aber das bringt dich mit und
auch noch möglich ist dass das stimmt
einfach mit deinem glück
es ist ein mutiger moncoutie und muss
ich das auto bisher
das gut so
herbert untersucht mein herzschlag und
mister
blutdruckwerte sport ist für mich
ungefährlich max und transport machen
muss übrigens keine angst vor einem
herzinfarkt erklärte berg ich möchte ihn
jetzt noch wissen was ein vater
besprochen effekt auf gesundheit hatte
ich bin überall spricht stoße von ludwig
seiten sie an die depression so die
anderen also der weiß man mittlerweile
bei der depression das ist in ordnung es
seelische krankheit sondern das betrifft
ganz siemens inklusive körper und das
wird übrigens eingesetzt ich weiß von
mindestens einer psychosomatischen
klinik wo schon seit längerem hält
kamera hat wo das gesetz
depressionen man erzählt sich sehr viel
von der positive effekt
eine wo immer vor und sieht sich durch
corona wie so ein buch
verstärkt simon system da bin ich
überzeugt dass de fragt geht klarer fall
einfach in die seriöse wissenschaftliche
wald will ich noch nie gewesen was aber
die griechen sind wir mit dem saunieren
war also temperaturdifferenzen
heilsbringer temperaturen aus
schlagartig zander das hat zweifellos
auswirkungen auf die ganze organismus
inklusive immunsystem welche rolle
spielte arten mit dem ganz das was was
kann man mit so einem meter erreichen
wie im hof dort ja ganz viele sinne
tutorials das ist das
hyperventilieren ich bin jetzt aber nur
sofern von deinem vorgehen von apple
niederlegen das haben die überhaupt
nicht hören aber das modul atemtechnik
einen positiven effekt stifter körper
kann auslöser sei verständlich da hat
wim hof
neues entdeckt der wert bestätigt mir
auf dass entzündungswerte und
muskelverspannungen durch kälte und
richtige atmen zu können die alte
gesundheitliche benefiz-cd aber aus
limit
mehrere verhör griffe aber vielleicht
weniger oder anders trank mit einer
mittleren bessere widerstandsfähigkeit
als nachdem sprechen
witzig das ist sicher auch mit dem
versuch das
wohlbefinden wo liegen jetzt insgesamt
einfach zurück nur hat dass das
klima vor dem mund
die dritte woche von musik wird schon
langsam zur gewohnheit ich gegangen ist
wasser ganz egal ob es regnet schneit
produziert und fühle mich enorm witt
richtig spaß macht richtig freude hatte
[Musik]
ich kann diese frage ist nur wichtig ist
das ist aber das glück
und
du
[Musik]
der wert hat mir erklärt warum sich nach
dem sport so vorzulegen und damit unsere
warme dusche flüchtet roter blutstrom
ist nämlich von extremität des herz
umfang zu
toppen
wo wir jahr ist die studioleiterin
geschafft und gewohnt hat abgerissen
wurde in der persönlichen krise anderen
workshop im hof zurück und bin dann am
schluss dieser woche wirklich oben ohne
drischt und uhren schneesturm auf ein
bayerischer für prof mit dem zusammen
und glücklich 7 in der gruppe 70
jährigen frauen
mit wo sie sind und allianz geschafft
und das ist
eindrücklich und darum mache ich das
immer noch besetzt das ist sachlich als
kritiker über das fest sucht das krasse
zeitwert herrschaft aus so lang ist das
egal und das weniger der vorkoster
fischhaber wirklich blüht auf es ist
eine situation wo extrem ist wie jede
ich mache es jetzt irgendwie vier jahre
lang und jeden morgen wenn ich das mache
ich schreien immer noch es ist nicht so
dass ich es irgendwie ist er finde oder
mich jetzt mega darauf freue ich mich
aufs gefühl nach hin und ich weiß dass
mir irgendwie hilft mich gesund sport
und das - schüttet das ist geil also ich
bin also gesagt niemals wirklich ist
wieso corinne suter ich muss bis es mehr
ich muss konserve und so sachen oder
porto das ist so mein style und jetzt an
die bauern im wind wie ein shift gremien
und ich glaube es darum hat die
mannschaft auch eine die youtube wo das
event
findet am
nachdem wir nach
vorne sehen
ist
das ist geil
sie terry spot sehr viel weniger krank
die größten vorteile der dort wo aber
darin dass im alltag besser mit
stresssituationen kann ungar balázs
künstler und personen mit bühnenpräsenz
hat er nämlich viel mit unsicher
situationen und kritik kampf
[Musik]
also
sitzen trick mit dem teils ich hoffe bis
auf gaddafi mit überlegen
seitdem sie da sieht wie sie da sie
ersatzlos weg schmelzen wenn man dort
und jetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er blieb stumm extreme
gibt die den körper oder irgendwie so
nimbus
ist
eine heimliche competition musik sei ja
als schaffens zehn minuten
mit gewinne so ich weiß noch 23 minute
passierte bis hämisch in krippe dass er
auch anders sich verhalte in etwa und
deren papiere schossen zusammen
genommen hast du nicht gestoppt canamex
gestoppt ja der erste woche handeln das
ist baufällig gemacht dann vorhang ist
ich bin ubisoft
länge und
muss jetzt muss nötigen wir dienen den
sturkopf zu bringen
minute das ist ist
das armeebudget bist siehst du das
machst 100pro
jetzt grinst ist oder ein kleiner oder
was auch immer
schlosses hilft er als mensch zum wissen
wie connect und wisse dass du meinst du
dich über die gesundheit über überdies
lapan
das hat der cup
[Musik]
es ist die letzte woche von visage
versuche es kostet mich immer neue
windiges wasser stieg aber ich danke
mental hanni fortschritt gemacht ich
blieben entspannt und flüchte mich nach
dem bau der kita
gehört sieht stoffe und versorgung des
buches lohse ich bin total weg vor dem
leistungsgedanken dumont die eigentlich
alltägliches wasser
gott was mach ich da eigentlich
das hat sich der ganztag
und
jetzt da in segen werden verschiedene
vertikale
will valve knackte die ort hat jetzt ist
am abend nach dem sport fühle mich wach
auch der samstag versucht
und sich
überschlug und
mache jetzt einen corner test der
testfahrt negatives ich mache trotzdem
tat mir und fühle mich am nächsten tag
mit reichlich wasser und tee trinken und
zwar nicht weil ich mich als aufwärmer
villiger wiesbaden will sondern will ich
noch 28 tages bade und jede frau die
ihrem hobby gemacht krank war oder bin
ich
bin verschnupft und fühle mich wach und
bei anderen art versuche im allgemeinen
ist mir aber sehr gut gang im letzten
monat die größte chance sieht als ich
nach freitag bereits muss aufrecht im
bett liegt was mich im letzten monat
überrascht hat ist das so viel positive
effekt wird erklärt exposition und vor
der wm hatten techniker sowohl von der
schulmedizin als auf worte wie im hof
community bestätigt werden sie sind sich
aber auch in dem punkt einig dass man
nämlich amt wird ich meine ich bis beste
beispiel dafür ich schaute sie von den
methoden ist dass man im ursächlich
schmerz aushalten also vor allem in der
ersten woche oder der escheck war
marlies potter muss man auch der schmerz
erhältlich eine seite und das buch der
disziplin also noch einmal ist dort hat
man die gewünschte effekt man hat zwar
die glücksformel wir sind unbestritten
aber die andere effekte es braucht viel
training aber was haltet ihr von dem hof
methode oder zum star der allgemein gebe
es nur durch der uni kommentar und auf
einen neuwagen antwortest unbeantwortet
sind wird sich im juni auf sand oder
andere thema egal und wenn ihr die
reportage auch so gut kundenhand wenig
dann vergesse kanal zu abonnieren